Mày 2 mấy sò thống mới, tổng tùng Mỹ đồ nân trăm kỳ kế tỏ thận thường mại với Thái Lan,
Balicea và Cam Mu Chià, những thật này phà lành kế tâm cận mới của Mỹ tại đông nè mạ.
Kế tỏng dưới trí lời thay thui quan và bảo đam một khoảng 3 thi điều.
Thều đó, Mỹ sẽ mức thời mổi chính phần chăm, đối với phần lớn nặng hỏi từ bán hôm nay.
Đoài lại, Thái Lan, số bảo vệ như toàn bộ hàng giáo thử với Hạ Mỹ,
Balicea thì Cam Kếc không hảm chế xuất khổ đất hiếm và khoảng 3 quan chọng sang thịt Trung Mỹ,
con cám buồn chia, tham gia và khôn khổ chung về lợi đậm và mua chiên.
Nhưng mới đi này, năm trong trị lượng đã giảng hoa trộ của mướng, giảng phục thuộc và Trung Quốc,
đã biệt trong lĩnh bởi khoảng 3 phục vụ công nghệ cao.
Bởi những mức tiền mới đặt được, ngoái chính tình cũng đồng thời khẳng định,
sẵn sàng tham kế lâu ra về ASEAN, tạo ra kìm wind fang,
nếu hay bên suy chiế hợp tám dự trị lời trị lời trị lời trị lời, vạc tâm bảo lưỡi kinh tế.